- Vítej zpět u kurzu Pochopení
kvantových informací a výpočtů.
Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel
pro IBM Quantum Education.
Toto je třetí lekce série. V prvních dvou lekcích jsme mluvili o základech
kvantových informací.
Nejprve pro jednotlivé systémy v izolaci a pak pro více systémů.
Také jsme diskutovali o měřeních
ve standardní bázi a unitárních operacích jak v případě
jednotlivých, tak i vícenásobných systémů.
V této lekci představíme
model kvantového circuit, který nám dává standardní způsob, jak popisovat kvantové výpočty,
a kvantové circuit můžeme také použít k popisu kvantových protokolů a jiných druhů interakcí zahrnujících více kvantových zařízení.
Kromě kvantových circuit budeme také diskutovat o některých
důležitých matematických konceptech spojených s kvantovými informacemi,
a použijeme je k pozorování
několika základních omezení kvantových informací a toho, co s kvantovými circuit můžeme dělat.
To nás dobře připraví na
lekci, která následuje po této, kde uvidíme několik
velmi důležitých příkladů a to uzavře
první část série
o základech kvantových informací.
Zde je přehled lekce. Začneme modelem kvantového circuit a uvidíme, jak funguje.
Pak budeme mluvit o
zásadně důležitém pojmu skalárního součinu, stejně jako o ortonormalitě a projekcích,
které jsou se skalárními součiny spojeny. Tyto věci jsme nediskutovali
v prvních dvou lekcích, protože jsme je
opravdu nepotřebovali, ale teď ano.
Skalární součiny nám poskytují
matematický nástroj, bez kterého se jednoduše neobejdeme.
Prostě bychom se daleko nedostali v porozumění kvantovým informacím a
výpočtům bez skalárních součinů.
A ve třetí části lekce se podíváme na
několik důležitých omezení kvantových informací.
V konečném důsledku chceme zkoumat zajímavé
věci, které můžeme dělat s kvantovými informacemi, ale abychom to mohli dělat efektivně,
musíme si být vědomi některých
věcí, které dělat nemůžeme.
Zejména budeme diskutovat
o pojmu globální fáze a proč jsou globální fáze irelevantní.
Uvidíme formulaci
věty o nemožnosti klonování, která nám říká, že kvantové stavy obecně nelze kopírovat, a uvidíme, že dva kvantové stavy
nelze dokonale
rozlišit, pokud nejsou ortogonální, což je základní
omezení, které si je třeba uvědomit.
Prvním tématem lekce
je model kvantového circuit, což je model výpočtu,
který nám poskytuje způsob,
jak popisovat kvantové výpočty.
Model kvantového circuit je
založen na obecnějším pojmu z informatiky, a to circuit, a můžeš definovat mnoho
různých modelů výpočtu
na základě tohoto obecného pojmu.
Základní myšlenka je, že
circuit se skládá z drátů, které nesou informace, a gate, které představují operace
aplikované na informace
nesené dráty.
Termín circuit je vlastně
trochu podivné jméno pro tento druh modelu,
protože slovo circuit
obvykle odkazuje na
kruhovou cestu určitého druhu.
Ale když mluvíme o circuit
jako modelech výpočtu, obvykle mluvíme
o acyklických circuit
kde kruhové cesty nejsou povoleny.
Abychom byli přesnější, pro
účely této série budeme požadovat, aby
informace vždy tekly zleva doprava v každém circuit.
Takže pokud chceš, můžeš
přemýšlet o circuit jako o popisech sekvencí operací, kde čas plyne zleva doprava.
Zde je příklad Booleovského circuit, kde dráty nesou binární
hodnoty, buď nula nebo jedna,
a gate představují
Booleovské logické operace.
Dráty jsou reprezentovány přímkami a zde máme dva vstupní
bity označené X a Y,
a pokud chceme vědět,
co circuit dělá na konkrétní volbě vstupů, propagujeme hodnoty na
drátech zleva doprava,
v závislosti na akcích,
které gate provádějí na hodnotách, které jsou
neseny dráty.
Takže například se můžeme
podívat na to, co se stane, když začneme s horním vstupním drátem nastaveným na hodnotu jedna a dolním vstupním drátem
nastaveným na hodnotu nula.
Tyto dva vstupní dráty vedou
do těchto dvou bodů hned tady, které představují fan-out operace, což znamená, že hodnota je zkopírována
takže ji lze nést
dále podél více drátů.
Pokud to tedy uděláme, pak tyto
dva dráty mají hodnotu jedna, stejnou jako tato jedna, a tyto dva dráty mají hodnotu nula,
stejnou jako tato nula.
Zde máme gate NOT, který
je indikován symbolem pro logickou negaci, takže
hodnota, která vychází, je nula,
což je logická negace jedničky. A podobně, hodnota
vycházející z tohoto gate je jedna, což je
logická negace nuly.
Tyto dva gate jsou gate AND,
tento gate je gate OR, a pokud budeme pokračovat
a propagovat hodnoty
WEBVTT
skrze circuit, správně vyhodnocujíce
gate, pak vidíme, že konečná hodnota
na tomto drátu je jedna.
Celý circuit tedy popisuje
sekvenci operací, které jsou složeny, jak schéma naznačuje, a skončíme s funkcí
od dvou bitů k jednomu bitu
v tomto konkrétním případě. Ale obecně může být libovolný počet
vstupních a výstupních bitů.
Tento konkrétní circuit náhodou počítá exkluzivní OR dvou vstupních bitů, takže výstup je jedna
tehdy a jen tehdy, pokud právě
jeden ze dvou vstupních bitů je nastaven na jedničku a druhý je nastaven na nulu, ale to není
důležité, je to jen příklad.
Je to základní fakt o Booleovských circuit, že každou funkci od libovolného počtu bitů k libovolnému počtu bitů lze vypočítat
nějakým Booleovským circuit, i když někdy by mohl
být potřeba velmi velký circuit k výpočtu funkce,
která tě zajímá.
Existují i jiné styly, které
se používají k popisu circuit.
Například tento obrázek
představuje přesně stejný circuit jako předtím, s použitím stylu, který je možná typičtější
v elektrotechnice, kde existují konvence pro tvary, které reprezentují různé gate.
Tento konkrétní styl nebudeme
používat, ale zavedeme
vlastní symboly pro různé kvantové gate, jako jsou Hadamard gate,
řízené NOT gate,
Toffoli gate a tak dále.
Jen poznámka na okraj: zde vidíme původ
termínu circuit.
V kontextu elektrotechniky je velmi přirozené
přemýšlet o elektřině procházející circuit.
Ale v této sérii nemluvíme
o elektřině pohybující se skrze circuit, mluvíme o informacích
pohybujících se skrze circuit.
A opět pro nás budou vždy acyklické, kde informace
se pohybují zleva doprava.
Zde je jiný příklad
jiného druhu circuit, nazývá se aritmetický circuit.
Tentokrát dráty ukládají čísla a gate představují
aritmetické operace jako sčítání a násobení.
Zde vidíš příklad
aritmetického circuit.
Pro účely
této lekce není důležité, co dělá, je to jen příklad, který má
zprostředkovat myšlenku, že existují různé
pojmy circuit.
Můžeme také přemýšlet o
circuit zahrnujících náhodnost, například kde gate představují
pravděpodobnostní operace, a pokud by ses chtěl,
mohl bys pravděpodobně strávit celý den vymýšlením nových modelů výpočtu na základě pojmu circuit.
V modelu kvantového circuit
dráty představují qubit, a gate představují jak unitární operace, tak i měření.
Zde je velmi jednoduchý příklad
kvantového circuit.
V tomto circuit je jen jeden qubit, který je reprezentován
vodorovnou přímkou, a gate, které jsou
označeny čtverci,
představují unitární operace prováděné na tomto qubit.
V tomto konkrétním příkladu
tedy nejsou žádná měření.
Pokud chceme dát
qubit jméno jako X, můžeme to v diagramu naznačit umístěním X přímo
sem, to je volitelné.
Stejně jako u Booleovského circuit před chvílí, můžeme o tomto circuit
přemýšlet jako o reprezentaci sekvence operací, kde čas
plyne zleva doprava.
Začínáme tedy s X,
aplikujeme první gate, což je Hadamard gate,
za nímž následuje gate S,
pak další Hadamard
gate a nakonec gate T.
Tyto operace jsme viděli
ke konci lekce jedna, a zde vidíš
jejich maticové popisy.
Takže když provedeme tyto
čtyři operace v pořadí, což znamená nejprve H, pak
S, pak H znovu a pak T,
kombinovaná operace je dána
tímto součinem přímo zde, přičemž mějme na paměti, že pořadí
se v podstatě obrátí
jak jsme o tom mluvili v lekci jedna. Pokud provedeme maticové násobení, dostaneme tuto matici přímo zde,
a tak akce
circuit na qubit X je popsána touto unitární maticí.
Někdy bychom chtěli explicitně v diagramu kvantového circuit
naznačit, jaký vstup přivádíme, a to můžeme udělat, jak vidíš právě zde.
V tomto případě přivádíme
Ket 0 do circuit.
To je celkem běžné. Často bereme Ket 0 jako
inicializovaný stav qubit, ale to není nutné.
Mohli bychom také uvažovat
o aplikaci circuit na jiný stav.
Pokud se rozhodneme, můžeme také
naznačit výstupní stav, který dostaneme, takto.
Zde je další příklad, kde
tentokrát máme dva qubit pojmenované X a Y, jak
vidíš v diagramu.
Zde máme Hadamard gate, který je aplikován na qubit Y, za nímž následuje gate označený
tímto symbolem přímo zde,
což je řízený NOT gate. O
řízené NOT operaci jsme mluvili v předchozí lekci,
a zde v tomto diagramu vidíme,
že řídící qubit je Y, který je označen
malým vyplněným kroužkem,
a cílový qubit je X, který je označen velkým kroužkem s tím, co vypadá jako znaménko plus uvnitř.
Trochu to připomíná
symbol pro exkluzivní OR, takže to dává smysl.
WEBVTT
Můžeš si představit, že cokoli
klasický stav uložený v Y se XORuje na qubit X.
A jen v zájmu jasnosti, zde je diagram, který
ukazuje akci tohoto gate na standardní bázové stavy,
kde předpokládáme, že A
a B jsou binární hodnoty.
Pro ostatní stavy je akce určena
linearitou, jako vždy.
Dříve než půjdeme dál, bude užitečné
explicitně uvést konvenci, kterou budeme dodržovat ohledně toho, jak jsou qubit uspořádány
v diagramech kvantového circuit, jako je tento.
A tou konvencí je, že
uspořádání zdola nahoru v diagramu kvantového circuit odpovídá uspořádání zleva doprava
jako v n-tici nebo tenzorové součinu.
Tuto konvenci budeme
dodržovat v sérii a je to také konvence
používaná v Qiskit.
Takže pro tento konkrétní circuit přemýšlíme o něm jako o
operaci na dvojici qubit X, Y,
X je první, protože je dole, a Y je poslední nebo druhý v tomto případě, protože je nahoře.
Způsob, jak si to vizuálně představit,
v případě, že to pomůže, je představit si otočení
tohoto circuit po směru hodinových ručiček, takže vstupy jsou nahoře
a výstupy jsou dole, a uspořádání
qubit bude správné.
Toto uspořádání někdy lidi mate, takže si tuto
konvenci určitě zapamatuj.
Když tedy přemýšlíme o akci, kterou tento circuit popisuje, máme nejprve
Hadamard gate aplikovaný na Y
a pak řízený NOT
gate na dvou qubit, kde Y je řídící
a X je cíl.
Pokud chceme zapsat unitární matici, která popisuje kombinovanou
akci těchto dvou gate, můžeme to udělat.
Nejprve uvažujeme Hadamard gate na Y.
Aplikujeme Hadamard gate na Y a s X nic neděláme, což je ekvivalentní s
provedením operace identity na X.
A tak akce Hadamard gate na oba qubit dohromady je
dána tenzorový součinem matice identity a
matice reprezentující
Hadamard operaci na Y.
Vypadá to takto, přičemž mějme na paměti naši
konvenci, že X je první a Y je druhý, takže je to
identita tenzorována s H.
Pak aplikujeme
řízenou NOT operaci, která má toto maticové
vyjádření, a opět je to konzistentní s naší konvencí.
Druhý qubit Y je řídící a první qubit X je cíl.
Neboj se video zastavit a ověřit, že to dává smysl, a přestanu tě na to upozorňovat.
Tato videa můžeš pozastavovat, vracet se zpět a sledovat části
tolikrát, kolikrát chceš, upravit rychlost přehrávání podle svého uvážení, používat je jakýmkoli
způsobem, který ti nejlépe vyhovuje.
Každopádně, když složíme
dvě operace dohromady, kombinovaná akce je popsána
tímto součinem přímo zde,
a tyto dvě matice jsou
násobeny v tomto pořadí, protože Hadamard je proveden nejprve a řízený NOT
je proveden jako druhý,
a opět je to konzistentní
s tím, o čem jsme mluvili v lekci jedna, kde se pořadí
v podstatě obrátí.
Pokud provedeme maticové násobení, dostaneme tuto matici přímo zde.
A nyní můžeme z této matice přečíst, co circuit dělá se
standardními bázovými stavy.
Pokud spustíme circuit na vstupu 0, 0, tedy Ket 0 pro první qubit, Ket 0 pro druhý qubit,
výsledkem je Bellův stav Phi+, což vidíme z
prvního sloupce matice.
Pokud přivedeme 0, 1, dostaneme stav Phi-, jedna nula nám dá stav Psi+,
a 1, 1 nám dá ne Psi-, ale -1 krát Psi-.
Znaménko mínus tady není
opravdu podstatné. Pokud bys to nechtěl mít tady, mohl bys provést swap
operaci na dvou qubit
abys ho odstranil a
nenarušil to, co se stalo s prvními třemi standardními bázovými stavy.
Ale pro účely tohoto příkladu
to opravdu není důležité.
Takže shrnuto, circuit má tuto akci přímo zde na standardní bázové stavy.
Když přemýšlíš o tom,
co konkrétní circuit dělá, nemusíš procházet
převod na matice a násobit je dohromady,
můžeš také sledovat
akci, kterou circuit provádí na konkrétních stavech, a v mnoha případech to bude
preferovaná možnost.
V tomto příkladu například vidíme, co circuit
dělá se stavem 0, 0, zkoumáním akcí gate.
Počáteční stav, který
jsme zde pojmenovali Pi nula, jen abychom se vyhnuli jménu,
které by bylo matoucí s Bellovými stavy, je 0, 0.
Aplikujeme Hadamard gate a stav, který dostaneme, je 0+, který můžeme rozepsat takto,
a pak řízená NOT operace vezme tento stav do stavu Phi+, což vidíme přemýšlením
o akci, kterou řízený NOT provádí na
standardní bázové stavy,
A totéž můžeš udělat
pro ostatní tři standardní bázové stavy nebo pro
jakýkoli jiný stav.
Můžeme také začlenit klasické bity do diagramů kvantového circuit.
Jsou označeny
dvojitými přímkami, jak vidíš v tomto diagramu.
To znamená, že A a B jsou klasické bity a X a Y jsou qubit.
WEBVTT
Máme stejné dva unitární gate jako v předchozím příkladu, a tyto symboly přímo zde představují měření ve standardní bázi
Konkrétně po provedení dvou
unitárních operací je provedeno měření ve standardní bázi
na Y
a výsledek je přepsán
do klasického bitu B, a podobně X je změřeno a výsledek je zapsán do bitu A.
Zde vidíš, že qubit X a Y pokračují dál poté, co jsou změřeny.
Je to docela běžné,
že nám příliš nezáleží na qubit
poté, co jsou změřeny.
Někdy nás zajímá jen
výsledek měření. A v takovém případě můžeme použít zkrácený
styl, který vidíš zde
kde měření mají qubit vstupující a klasické bity vystupující.
Rozumí se, že
jakmile jsou qubit změřeny, jsou jednoduše zahozeny nebo ignorovány a klasický výsledek
měření je nesen dál.
Jak série pokračuje, budeme vidět mnoho
příkladů kvantových circuit a ty budou typicky
mnohem složitější než velmi jednoduché
příklady, které jsme právě viděli.
Jak jsem zmínil dříve, různé symboly se
používají pro různé gate.
Jednoqubitová gate se obvykle
zapisují jako čtverce s písmenem označujícím,
o jakou operaci se jedná.
Někdy jsou tato různá
gate barevně odlišena, aby znamenala různé věci, ale
to teď budeme ignorovat.
Řízený NOT gate jsme
už viděli.
Swap gate jsou označeny,
jak vidíš přímo zde, a Toffoli gate a Fredkin gate
jsou označeny, jak vidíš přímo zde.
Pamatuj, že Toffoli gate je řízený řízený NOT gate a Fredkin gate je
řízený swap gate.
Tyto symboly jsou tedy
konzistentní s myšlenkou, že řídící qubit je
označen plným kroužkem s přímkou spojující ho
s gate, který řídí.
Obecně řídící qubit
nemusí být nahoře a tyto gate nemusí
působit na sousední qubit, což znamená, že tyto gate
mohou přesahovat přes
ostatní qubit, na které nepůsobí, a to uvidíme
v budoucích lekcích.
Ještě jedna věc, kterou při použití modelu kvantového circuit často děláme, je zobrazovat libovolné unitární operace
na libovolném počtu qubit
jako by byly jednotlivými gate, jak vidíš přímo zde.
Stačí nakreslit obdélník s popiskem odpovídajícím
příslušné unitární operaci.
V tomto případě je to nějaká
unitární operace U.
Samozřejmě
nevíme, co U je z tohoto diagramu, musíme předpokládat, že
U je nějak definováno, nebo že uvažujeme nějakou libovolnou
unitární operaci U. Mohlo by být například, že
chceme prostě přemýšlet o U jako o podrutině
v zájmu přehlednosti.
Používáme také tuto notaci,
kterou vidíš přímo zde, pro řízenou U operaci,
kde řídící qubit je označen plným kroužkem,
stejně jako předtím.
To je tedy stručný úvod
do modelu kvantového circuit. A jak jsem řekl dříve, uvidíme mnohem více
příkladů kvantového circuit
jak budeme v sérii pokračovat.
V další části lekce se podíváme na
skalární součiny, ortonormalitu a projekce, což jsou velmi důležité pojmy
v kvantových informacích a výpočtech.
Začneme skalárními součiny.
Pamatuj, že když
používáme Diracovu notaci, ket je sloupcový vektor
a bra je řádkový vektor,
a konkrétně
bra vektor odpovídající danému sloupcovému vektoru je konjugovaný transponát
tohoto sloupcového vektoru.
Takže pro tento vektor přímo zde získáme odpovídající bra vektor transponováním vektoru
jako by to byla matice,
což znamená položit ho na bok a pak vzít komplexní konjugát každého z prvků.
Nyní předpokládejme, že máme dva ket se stejným počtem prvků, takto.
Pokud vytvoříme tuto závorku přímo zde, což jednoduše znamená, že
vezmeme součin bra a ket,
jako by to byly matice,
dostaneme tento výraz,
který vidíš přímo zde, což je skalár, neboli jinými slovy komplexní číslo.
Tato hodnota se nazývá skalární součin
těchto dvou vektorů.
O skalárních součinech můžeš také přemýšlet v termínech vektorů
ve formě, kterou vidíš přímo zde, kde vektory jsou vyjádřeny
jako lineární kombinace
standardních bázových vektorů.
Skalární součin těchto vektorů je definován stejným způsobem jako
předtím, bra Psi krát ket Phi, což můžeme vyjádřit
jako součin takto.
A pokud vypočítáme a zjednodušíme, zůstane nám tento výraz přímo zde pro skalární součin, který je analogický s tím, co jsme měli předtím,
jenže tentokrát
sumujeme přes prvky v naší množině klasických stavů, což je sigma v tomto konkrétním případě.
Zde je příklad, který má poskytnout geometrický obrázek pro
to, jak skalární součiny fungují.
Zde jsem nakreslil kružnici
v dvourozměrném prostoru odpovídající qubit, a pokud omezíme svou pozornost
na vektory s reálnými prvky, můžeme je nakreslit jako body v této rovině.
WEBVTT
Nechme Phi být
tímto vektorem přímo zde.
Je to jednotkový vektor, což vidíme výpočtem Euklidovské normy, a to je to, co tato kružnice představuje,
jsou to všechny jednotkové vektory
s reálnými prvky.
Nechme také Psi být
tímto vektorem přímo zde, který je rovněž jednotkovým vektorem.
Je to ve skutečnosti stav minus, ale zde ho jen nazýváme Psi.
Pokud vypočítáme skalární
součin těchto dvou vektorů, dostaneme jedna minus odmocnina ze tří dělená dvěma krát odmocnina ze dvou,
což je přibližně -1/4.
Hodnota tohoto skalárního součinu je rovna kosinu úhlu
mezi dvěma vektory, jak vidíš zde v obrázku.
To je obecně pravda pro jednotkové vektory. Pokud máme dva jednotkové vektory a oba mají reálné prvky,
pak je skalární součin mezi nimi roven kosinu
úhlu mezi nimi.
Zejména, pokud je skalární
součin roven nule, jako v tomto příkladu, kde jsme změnili Psi
na tento stav přímo zde,
pak musí být dva vektory
pod úhlem 90 stupňů k sobě navzájem.
To vše se zobecňuje na
vektory v libovolné dimenzi, mimochodem, pokud jsou
prvky reálná čísla, není to jen pro dvourozměrné vektory.
Pokud máme prvky z komplexních čísel, obrázek už moc nefunguje, ale přesto je skalární součin stejně
užitečný, jak uvidíme.
Skalární součin má některé
velmi důležité vlastnosti a věnujeme pár chvil pozorování některých z těchto vlastností nyní.
První je spojení
mezi skalárním součinem a Euklidovskou normou.
Pokud vezmeme skalární součin
libovolného vektoru se sebou samým, dostaneme Euklidovskou normu na druhou.
Alternativně tedy můžeme říci, že Euklidovská norma vektoru je rovna odmocnině skalárního součinu
tohoto vektoru se sebou samým. To není náhoda, to je
základní spojení, a zde vidíme, že kdybychom neměli
komplexní konjugáty v definici skalárního součinu, pak by tento vzorec
přestal platit a neměli bychom tak užitečný pojem
s tímto základním spojením
s Euklidovskou normou.
Dále, skalární součin
je konjugovaně symetrický, což znamená, že pokud prohodíme
pořadí dvou argumentů, hodnota skalárního součinu se konjuguje.
To je vyjádřeno
touto rovnicí přímo zde a je celkem přímočaré vidět, proč k tomu dochází pro tyto dva výrazy
pro skalární součin dvou vektorů ve dvou možných pořadích.
Skalární součin je lineární
ve druhém argumentu. Konkrétně, pokud definujeme vektor Phi jako tuto lineární
kombinaci dvou vektorů,
Phi jedna a Phi dva, pak je skalární součin
libovolného vektoru Psi s Phi stejnou lineární kombinací
dvou skalárních součinů,
a to plyne celkem
přímo ze skutečnosti, že maticové násobení je lineární.
A máme také, že skalární
součin je konjugovaně lineární v prvním argumentu, jak vidíš vyjádřeno přímo zde.
Pokud je Psi tato lineární
kombinace vektorů, pak pokud vezmeme skalární
součin Psi a Phi,
bra Psi se stane tímto vektorem, který vidíme přímo zde, kde vezmeme komplexní
konjugát beta jedna a beta dva,
a tak je toto výsledek a to je to, co se myslí
konjugovanou linearitou.
A poslední vlastnost skalárního součinu, kterou chci zmínit, je
nesmírně užitečná Cauchy-Schwarzova nerovnost.
Pro libovolné dva vektory Psi a Phi absolutní hodnota skalárního součinu nemůže být nikdy větší než součin Euklidovských norem
těchto dvou vektorů. A navíc, jediný způsob, jak mohou být obě
strany nerovnosti rovny, je, pokud jsou dva
vektory lineárně závislé,
což znamená, že jeden z nich je roven nějakému skaláru krát druhý.
Toto je ve skutečnosti jedna z
nejpoužívanějších nerovností v celé matematice a
používáme ji znovu a znovu, když mluvíme o
kvantových informacích,
takže je velmi dobré ji znát.
Dále budeme mluvit o
pojmech ortogonality a ortonormality, které jsou
spojeny se skalárními součiny
a konkrétně se skalárními součiny vektorů rovnými nule.
Přesněji, pokud máme
dva vektory Psi a Phi, říkáme, že jsou ortogonální,
pokud je jejich skalární součin
roven nule. A způsob, jak si můžeme ortogonální vektory intuitivně představit, je, že jsou
svírají pravý úhel,
nebo alternativně, že jsou
na sebe kolmé.
Lidé někdy používají termín ortogonální k označení věcí, které spolu
nemají nic společného, jako když se řekne, že jeden problém
je ortogonální k jinému,
ale to je zjevně docela neformální a není to opravdu smysluplné
v matematickém smyslu, ale spojení je jasné, pokud přemýšlíš o ortogonálních
vektorech jako ukazujících
ne v opačných směrech, ale v úplně různých směrech, jako sever versus západ například.
Pokud máme množinu vektorů, říkáme, že množina je ortogonální množina, pokud jsou libovolné dva různé vektory
vybrané z této množiny
nutně ortogonální k sobě navzájem, což můžeme vyjádřit,
jak vidíš přímo zde,
WEBVTT
Ortonormální množina je
prostě ortogonální množina jednotkových vektorů.
Vektory v ortogonálních
množinách nemusí být nutně jednotkové vektory a ve skutečnosti by mohl být dokonce nulový vektor
prvkem ortogonální množiny, ale v ortonormální množině musí být každý vektor jednotkovým vektorem
kromě
požadavku, že množina je ortogonální množinou.
Vzhledem k tomu, co víme o vztahu mezi skalárním součinem
a Euklidovskou normou, můžeme tuto
podmínku vyjádřit celkem stručně
jak vidíš přímo zde.
A konečně, ortonormální báze je prostě ortonormální
množina, která tvoří bázi pro jakýkoli vektorový prostor,
o kterém mluvíme.
Například, pokud vezmeme libovolnou
množinu klasických stavů sigma a uvažujeme množinu
všech standardních bázových vektorů,
vidíme, že toto je ortonormální množina, a ve skutečnosti je to ortonormální báze pro prostor všech vektorů, jejichž prvky odpovídají
této množině klasických stavů sigma.
Jsou to všechny jednotkové vektory a
jsou ortogonální v párech, takže je to ortonormální množina.
a protože je to také báze, máme, že je to ortonormální báze.
Ortonormální množiny jsou
vždy lineárně nezávislé, takže kdykoli
máš ortonormální množinu, bude vždy ortonormální
bází pro nějaký podprostor,
ale v tomto případě máme bázi pro celý prostor, se kterým pracujeme.
Dalším příkladem je množina
obsahující ket+ a ket-.
Tyto dva vektory jsou ortogonální, jejich skalární součin je roven nule.
a jsou to oba jednotkové vektory a pokrývají
dvourozměrný prostor vektorů odpovídající jedinému qubit, takže tvoří ortonormální
bázi pro tento prostor.
Dalším příkladem je Bellova báze, která je ortonormální bází pro prostor všech
čtyřrozměrných vektorů odpovídajících dvěma qubit.
Množina obsahující ket 0
a ket+ na druhou stranu není ortogonální množinou, protože skalární součin mezi
těmito vektory je nenulový.
Jsou to oba jednotkové vektory a toto je báze pro vektorový prostor odpovídající qubit, ale nemáme ortogonalitu.
Zde je užitečný fakt o ortonormálních množinách, který budeme čas od času využívat.
Předpokládejme, že máme nějakou
ortonormální množinu vektorů, konkrétně předpokládejme,
že máme M vektorů v této množině, Psi jedna až Psi M,
kde předpokládáme, že tyto vektory jsou z nějakého N
rozměrného vektorového prostoru, nebo jinými slovy, každý z
vektorů má M prvků.
Jak jsem již zmínil, ortonormální množiny jsou vždy
lineárně nezávislé, takže nemůže být, že M je větší než N,
ale mohlo by být, že M je menší než N, a to je případ,
který nás zajímá.
A co fakt říká, je,
že pokud je M menší než N, pak je vždy možné
přidat další vektory
k množině, se kterou jsme začali, abychom získali
ortonormální bázi pro náš prostor.
Přesněji, musí
nutně existovat vektory Psi M+1 až Psi N tak, aby celá kolekce
tvořila ortonormální bázi.
Nikdy se tedy nedostaneš do slepé uličky, abych tak řekl, tím, že bys nějak zvolil
ortonormální množinu vektorů, kterou nelze rozšířit tak, aby
tvořila ortonormální bázi.
Někdy se stačí podívat
na množinu, se kterou začínáš, a přijít na to, jak ji rozšířit na ortonormální bázi, ale alternativou, která vždy funguje,
je použít postup známý jako Gram-Schmidtův
ortogonalizační proces k sestrojení těchto vektorů.
Tento postup
v této lekci ani v této sérii nevysvětlím, protože specifika
pro nás nejsou
opravdu důležitá, ale samozřejmě si ho můžeš vyhledat, pokud tě to zajímá.
Jde o něco, co může
provést počítač, v případě, že je to relevantní, takže
nejde o žádnou kreativitu, je to jen mechanický postup.
Jedním z důvodů, proč je to
tak užitečný fakt, je jeho úzká spojitost, která existuje mezi ortonormálními
bázemi a unitárními maticemi.
Zejména, pro libovolnou čtvercovou matici U jsou tři podmínky, které vidíš zde, vždy ekvivalentní,
což znamená, že jsou buď
všechny pravdivé nebo jsou všechny nepravdivé.
První podmínka říká,
že U je unitární matice, což znamená, že jak U dagger krát U, tak U krát U dagger jsou obě
rovny matici identity.
Druhá podmínka
říká, že řádky U tvoří ortonormální bázi,
a třetí podmínka říká, že sloupce U
tvoří ortonormální bázi.
Ve skutečnosti není příliš těžké
vidět, proč tato ekvivalence platí.
Jen pro jednoduchost se podívejme na
matici U tři krát tři, jak vidíš přímo zde, kde prvky mohou být libovolná
komplexní čísla.
Zde vlevo jsem zapsal U konjugovaně transponované
jen pro pohodlí.
Pokud vytvoříme tři vektory
ze sloupců U, které jsou zde pojmenovány Psi
jedna, Psi dva a Psi tři, a pokud vezmeme
součin U dagger a U,
můžeš ověřit, že každý
prvek součinu je dán skalárním součinem vektorů, jak vidíme přímo zde v tomto vzoru.
A nyní, když přemýšlíš o podmínce, že U je unitární, což je ekvivalentní tomu, že tato matice je rovna matici identity,
vidíš, že je to ekvivalentní
s tím, že tři vektory tvoří ortonormální množinu.
Diagonální prvky musí být
všechny rovny jedné, takže to jsou nutně jednotkové vektory, a mimodynamické
prvky musí být nula,
takže je to ortogonální množina vektorů.
WEBVTT
Takže to, že U je unitární, je ekvivalentní tomu, že sloupce tvoří ortonormální množinu,
a to musí být báze, protože počet vektorů v množině, což je tři v tomto případě, souhlasí s dimenzí prostoru
se kterým pracujeme. Analogický argument lze použít pro řádky místo sloupců a dojít k závěru, že to, že U je
unitární, je ekvivalentní
tomu, že řádky tvoří ortonormální bázi.
Nefunguje to úplně tak elegantně, protože musíme provést úpravu, aby komplexní konjugáty
fungovaly správně, ale myšlenka je stejná.
Alternativní způsob, jak to provést, který je celkem přímočarý, je dokázat, že matice je unitární tehdy a jen tehdy, pokud je její transponát unitární.
A zde myslím opravdu transponát a ne konjugovaný transponát.
Z definice unitárních matic je celkem triviální, že konjugovaný transponát
libovolné unitární matice je unitární,
ale platí také, že transponát libovolné unitární matice je unitární.
V každém případě máme
ekvivalenci mezi těmito třemi podmínkami na libovolné čtvercové matici U, a tuto ekvivalenci lze kombinovat
s faktem o
rozšiřování ortonormálních množin na ortonormální báze, abychom přišli s unitárními maticemi
které dělají zajímavé věci
nebo splňují různé potřeby, se kterými se můžeme setkat.
Konkrétně, kdykoli
máme ortonormální množinu M vektorů, vždy bude existovat unitární matice U
jejíž prvních M sloupců jsou vektory z této ortonormální množiny.
Zbývající sloupce
lze vždy doplnit tak, abychom získali unitární matici výběrem tak, aby sloupce tvořily
ortonormální bázi. To bude pro nás docela
užitečný fakt.
A jedno další téma pro
tuto část lekce je pojem projekce.
Čtvercová matice Pi se
nazývá projekce nebo projekční matice, pokud obě vlastnosti,
které jsou zde uvedeny, jsou pravdivé.
Mimochodem, je to velké Pi, je to celkem typická volba písmene, které se používá pro označení projekce.
Takovým typickým názvům objektům jako jsou matice dáváme obvykle proto, aby bylo snazší je rozpoznat a udržet věci přehledné,
ale mohl bys použít jakékoli jméno chceš. Každopádně, první podmínka je, že Pi se rovná svému vlastnímu konjugovanému transponátu.
Obecně, pokud máme matici, která se rovná svému vlastnímu
konjugovanému transponátu, říkáme, že je to Hermitovská matice.
Takže první podmínku lze alternativně formulovat jako: Pi je Hermitovská.
Druhá podmínka je,
že pokud umocníme Pi, tedy násobíme Pi
samo sebou, dostaneme Pi znovu.
Umocnění Pi tedy nic neudělá.
Intuitivně je myšlenka projekce
podobná v duchu promítání obrazu na plátno nebo spouštění
kolmice na přímku,
například. Když násobíš
vektor projekcí, v jistém smyslu děláš
část vektoru ponecháváš beze změny
a zbytek vynuluješ.
Takže pokud aplikuješ
projekci podruhé, nic to neudělá, protože
jsi již vynuloval část, kterou projekce vynuluje.
Příkladem projekce
je tato matice přímo zde pro libovolnou volbu jednotkového vektoru Psi.
Můžeme ověřit, že splňuje
požadované podmínky jednu po druhé.
Pro první vypočítáme
konjugovaný transponát a to je konjugovaný
transponát součinu.
Takže můžeme použít tento vzorec přímo zde pro konjugovaný transponát
součinu, abychom si pomohli.
Dostaneme součin
konjugovaných transponátů, ale pořadí se obrátí.
To se stane kvůli
části transponátu.
Takže pokud použijeme tento vzorec, dostaneme tuto rovnost přímo zde a pak ji můžeme zjednodušit a
vrátit se k původní matici.
Všimni si mimochodem, že jsme nepoužili skutečnost,
že Psi je jednotkový vektor.
Ve skutečnosti je tedy tato matice
Hermitovská pro libovolný vektor Psi, nejen pro jednotkové vektory.
A pro druhou, umocníme Pi a dostaneme
tento výraz přímo zde a ten je roven původní matici tentokrát
protože Psi je jednotkový vektor, takže tento skalární součin
přímo zde je roven jedné a to je místo, kde předpoklad,
že Psi je jednotkový vektor
vstupuje do hry.
Tento příklad můžeme zobecnit a začít s ortonormální množinou.
A pokud vytvoříme tuto matici přímo zde, kde sečteme projekce odpovídající jednotlivým vektorům, dostaneme projekci.
Zde na obrazovce vidíš výpočty, které to ukazují, a nechávám na tobě,
abys je prozkoumal, pokud chceš.
A podobně jako v prvním příkladu, je to druhá podmínka, kde je využita ortonormalita
množiny.
Co tato projekce dělá,
pokud ji násobíš vektorem, je promítnout tento
vektor na podprostor, který je rozepnut touto množinou vektorů,
což abstraktně je
jako spuštění kolmice na tento podprostor, a jakmile
jsi v tomto podprostoru, projekce nic nedělá.
Matice jako tyto jsou tedy
příklady projekcí, a nyní jsme ve skutečnosti vyčerpali
všechny možnosti.
Každá projekční matice má tuto formu pro nějakou volbu ortonormální množiny.
Nulová matice je projekce, takže musíme
se ujistit, že ji zahrneme, pokud chceme získat každou projekci.
WEBVTT
Jen aby bylo jasno, povolujeme
možnost, že M se rovná nule, a to nám dá prázdný součet,
který můžeme interpretovat jako nulovou matici.
Nyní, když máme
koncept projekce k dispozici, můžeme definovat obecnější
třídu kvantových měření známou jako projektivní měření.
Toto není nejobecnější
pojem měření, ale je výrazně obecnější než měření ve standardní bázi
a bude velmi
užitečné ho začlenit do našeho popisu
kvantových informací.
Projektivní měření je definováno libovolnou množinou projekcí,
která splňuje podmínku, kterou vidíš přímo zde, a to, že projekce
se sečtou do matice identity.
Zde M může být libovolné
kladné celé číslo, pokud jsou to všechno projekce a tato podmínka je splněna,
kolekce definuje
projektivní měření.
Měření popsané
takovou kolekcí funguje takto, když
měříš libovolný kvantový stav Psi.
Nejprve dostaneš výsledek
mezi jedna a M, kde M je počet projekcí.
Pro každý možný výsledek K je pravděpodobnost získání tohoto výsledku Euklidovská norma
na druhou vektoru, který dostaneš
násobením S s Pi
K, K-tou projekcí.
Tuto veličinu lze také zapsat,
jak vidíš přímo zde.
Tato rovnost vychází ze vztahu mezi Euklidovskou
normou a skalárním součinem spolu se skutečností,
že Pi K je projekce.
Z druhé formy, spolu s podmínkou, kterou máme na tyto projekce, vidíme hned, linearitou, že naše pravděpodobnosti
budou vždy součtem jedné,
přičemž mějme na paměti, že Psi
musí být jednotkový vektor.
A za druhé, za předpokladu, že
dostaneme výsledek K, stav systému
se zhroutí na kvantový stav, který dostaneme normalizací jakéhokoli
vektoru, který jsme dostali projekcí.
Za chvíli se podíváme na některé
příklady, ale předtím mi dovolte zmínit, že ve skutečnosti nepotřebujeme
číslovat možné
výsledky od jedna do M. Můžeme si zvolit jakákoli jména nebo symboly pro výsledky.
Zejména, pokud máme kolekci projekcí, které jsou označeny symboly
z nějaké množiny gama,
a splňují
stejnou podmínku jako předtím, tedy se sečtou
do matice identity, pak máme projektivní měření
které funguje přesně
stejně jako předtím.
Jediný rozdíl je, že povolujeme,
aby výsledky měření byly prvky této množiny gama, na rozdíl od celých čísel od jedna do M.
Pro náš první příklad
projektivního měření si všimněme, že
měření ve standardní bázi jsou projektivní měření.
V tomto případě je množina
výsledků měření stejná jako množina klasických stavů libovolného systému, který je měřen.
A množina projekcí,
která popisuje měření, je tato kolekce přímo zde, za předpokladu, že sigma je
množina klasických stavů
našeho systému. Jsou to všechno projekce
a pokud je sečteme, dostaneme matici identity, takže je to platné projektivní měření.
Abychom viděli, jak to funguje
s trochu více detailů, předpokládejme, že
máme nějaký libovolný stav zapsaný ve formě,
kterou vidíš přímo zde.
Pravděpodobnost, aby
měření dalo výsledek A, podle popisu
před chvílí, je tato hodnota přímo zde,
která se rovná
absolutní hodnotě na druhou odpovídající
složky vektoru Psi, což je to, co očekáváme.
Za podmínky, že výsledek je A, stav systému se stane tímto, opět podle
popisu před chvílí.
Pokud zjednodušíme, nedostaneme
přesně stav, který očekáváme, což je ket A.
Místo toho dostaneme ket A
vynásobený skalárem, a konkrétně, to je skalár s
absolutní hodnotou rovnou jedné,
takže je to komplexní číslo
na jednotkové kružnici.
Toto se nazývá globální fáze a o globálních fázích budeme brzy diskutovat, ale teď stručně, tento
stav je ekvivalentní ket A.
Tato globální fáze nemá
vlastně žádný význam a uvidíme proč,
až se dostaneme k diskuzi o globálních fázích.
Takže (nesrozumitelné) tuto otázku globálních fází, o které budeme mluvit za chvíli, vidíme, že měření ve standardní bázi
jsou ve skutečnosti projektivní měření. Pro další příklad, který je ve skutečnosti rozšířením
předchozího příkladu,
pokud provedeme měření ve standardní bázi
na systému X a s systémem Y nic neděláme, stejně jako jsme o tom mluvili
v předchozí lekci,
je to zcela ekvivalentní
s měřením systému X, Y.
S tímto projektivním
měřením přímo zde.
Máme tyto projekce odpovídající klasickým stavům X a tenzorujeme s identitou na Y
což odráží skutečnost, že
s Y nic neděláme.
Popis toho, jak
projektivní měření fungují obecně, nám říká,
co se stane v tomto příkladu, a nechávám na tobě,
abys ověřil, že je to ve skutečnosti
zcela ekvivalentní s tím, o čem jsme diskutovali v předchozí lekci.
To je velmi pěkné, protože tento popis projektivního
měření je v jistém smyslu čistší a vidíme, že se hodí do
tohoto obecnějšího obrázku.
WEBVTT
Zde je ještě jeden příklad
projektivního měření.
Toto je měření dvou qubit.
Pro toto měření
máme dvě projekce, a tedy dva možné
výsledky, kterými jsou nula a jedna.
Projekce jsou definovány
v termínech Bellových stavů, jak vidíš přímo zde.
První projekce je
na prostor rozepnutý třemi symetrickými Bellovými stavy a druhá projekce je
na jednorozměrný prostor
rozepnutý stavem Psi-, který je antisymetrický, nebo jinými slovy
ten, který se násobí
znaménkem mínus, pokud
provedeme swap operaci na dvou qubit.
Proč je toto zajímavé měření, uvidíme později v sérii.
Teď je to jen příklad,
který se spojuje s něčím, co jsme viděli dříve,
a to s Bellovou bází.
Poslední poznámka k projektivním měřením je, že kdykoli máš
projektivní měření, vždy ho můžeš implementovat
pomocí unitárních operací a
měření ve standardní bázi.
Pro tento konkrétní příklad
měření například můžeme sestavit kvantový circuit, který implementuje měření,
jak vidíš přímo zde.
Představujeme si, že horní
dva qubit jsou qubit, které měříme tímto projektivním měřením, a co můžeme udělat, je
zavést nový qubit
který začíná inicializovaný
ve stavu nula. Provedeme Hadamard gate,
za nímž následuje Fredkin gate, za nímž následuje další Hadamard gate,
a pokud změříme tento spodní qubit pomocí měření ve standardní bázi, efekt bude přesně stejný, jako kdybychom změřili horní dva qubit
projektivním měřením
z tohoto příkladu.
Dostaneme přesně stejné pravděpodobnosti pro dva výsledky a efekt, který měření má na horní dva qubit,
bude také stejný.
To vůbec není zřejmé. K pochopení toho je potřeba analýza a ta zde není ukázána.
Jak jsem již navrhl, na toto konkrétní měření se podrobněji podíváme v pozdější lekci a teď
je to jen jako příklad.
Důležitý poznatek je, že něco takového je vždy možné pro jakékoli projektivní měření, takže zavedením projektivních měření
nezískáme žádné další schopnosti
ale je to velmi užitečný koncept a budeme o projektivních měřeních často mluvit
jak budeme v sérii pokračovat. Poslední část této lekce se týká několika důležitých omezení
kvantových informací
a toho, co s kvantovými circuit můžeme dělat.
První omezení, které možná není ani tak omezením jako spíše degenerací, se týká problému globálních fází
o kterém jsem se zmínil před chvílí. Zde je definice toho, co máme na mysli, když odkazujeme na globální fázi.
Pokud máme dva
vektory kvantového stavu Psi a Phi tak, že jeden z nich se
rovná druhému vynásobenému nějakým komplexním číslem alfa,
pak říkáme, že stavy
se liší o globální fázi, nebo alternativně, že jsou ekvivalentní až na globální fázi.
Všimni si, že protože vektory kvantových stavů mají Euklidovskou normu rovnou jedné, jediný způsob, jak může tato
rovnice platit,
je pokud je absolutní hodnota
tohoto komplexního čísla rovna jedné, takže alfa
musí ležet na jednotkové kružnici.
Představme si, že máme
dva kvantové stavy takto, které se liší o globální fázi, a předpokládejme, že měříme stav Phi
měřením ve standardní bázi.
Pravděpodobnost získání libovolného výsledku A je dána tímto výrazem přímo zde, a pokud dosadíme
alfa krát Psi za Phi,
což můžeme udělat, protože
předpokládáme, že jsou si rovny, dostaneme tuto pravděpodobnost.
A pokud zjednodušíme pomocí skutečnosti, že alfa leží na
komplexní jednotkové kružnici, dostaneme tuto pravděpodobnost.
Pamatuj, že toto je pravděpodobnost, že měření Phi dá výsledek A, ale nyní vidíme,
že je to přesně stejné jako pravděpodobnost, že měření
Psi dá výsledek A,
takže absolutně
není žádný rozdíl v pravděpodobnostech různých výsledků pro tyto dva stavy.
Analogický argument nám říká obecněji, že pro jakékoli projektivní měření jsou pravděpodobnosti opět totožné.
Takže měřením nelze
rozlišit dva stavy, které
se liší o globální fázi, ani ve statistickém smyslu.
Konečně, pokud aplikujeme libovolnou unitární
operaci na stav Phi, pak opět dosazením, co dostaneme, je přesně
stejné komplexní číslo alfa
vynásobené s tím, co dostaneme aplikací stejné unitární
operace na stav Psi.
Takže tyto dva stavy se budou stále
lišit o globální fázi.
Závěr je, že tyto dva stavy jsou zcela nerozeznatelné, takže mezi nimi
není opravdu žádný rozdíl
z hlediska toho, co bychom
mohli případně zjistit provádění unitárních
operací a měření, a z tohoto důvodu
považujeme tyto dva
stavy za ekvivalentní, nebo pokud chceš, jsou to prostě dvě případně různé
vektorové reprezentace
stejného kvantového stavu.
Jak jsem řekl na
začátku diskuze, jde v podstatě o degeneraci
v tom, jak jsou kvantové stavy popsány vektory kvantových stavů.
V každém případě to znamená, že
jednoduše můžeme globální fáze ignorovat, stejně jako jsme to efektivně udělali, když jsme popsali měření ve standardní bázi
WEBVTT
jako projektivní měření. Mimochodem, tato degenerace se vyskytuje pouze ve zjednodušeném popisu
kvantových informací.
Když popisujeme kvantové
stavy pomocí maticí hustoty, jak budeme dělat v
třetí části série, budeme mít jedinečnou
maticovou reprezentaci
pro každý kvantový stav. Problém globálních fází
jednoduše nevznikne v obecném popisu
kvantových informací.
Je to ještě jeden přitažlivý aspekt
obecného popisu kvantových informací,
na který stále narážím, ale bez ohledu na to, globální
fáze nás nebudou trápit
protože je můžeme prostě
ignorovat.
Zde je velmi rychlý
příklad jen abys měl jasno v pojmu globální fáze.
Pokud máme stav mínus a záporný krát stav mínus, pak se tyto dva stavy
liší o globální fázi, a konkrétně máme
alfa rovné záporné jedné.
Na druhou stranu, pokud máme stav plus a stav mínus, pak nemáme dva stavy,
které se liší o globální fázi.
Jsou to ortogonální vektory, takže jsou lineárně nezávislé.
Říct, že dva vektory kvantových stavů se liší o globální fázi,
je ekvivalentní s tím, že vektory jsou lineárně závislé,
takže tyto vektory určitě
se neliší o globální fázi.
Je pravda, že jediný rozdíl je, že toto znaménko plus
se změní na toto znaménko mínus, ale to se nazývá
relativní fázový rozdíl.
To se liší od globální fáze, protože nenásobíme celý vektor komplexním číslem.
A to je konzistentní se skutečností, že dokážeme rozlišit
mezi těmito stavy, zejména, pokud
aplikujeme Hadamard operaci
a pak měříme, uvidíme nulu, pokud
stav byl stav plus, a jedničku, pokud stav byl stav mínus.
Dalším omezením kvantových informací, které uvidíme v této lekci,
je věta o nemožnosti klonování.
Zde je jedno formulování
věty o nemožnosti klonování a toto konkrétní
formulování věty je celkem konkrétní a specifické,
což usnadní diskuzi. Existují i jiné obecnější způsoby, jak formulovat větu o nemožnosti klonování,
ale zaměříme se na tuto pro teď.
Předpokládáme, že máme dva systémy X a Y, které mají stejnou množinu klasických stavů.
která se skládá z
celých čísel od nuly do D-1, kde D je alespoň dvě.
Není opravdu důležité, jak se klasické stavy jmenují, ale volbou těchto názvů to zjednodušíme.
Nejdůležitější
je, že existují alespoň dva různé klasické
stavy, takže se jinými slovy nezabýváme
triviálním a nezajímavým případem,
kdy máme pouze jeden klasický stav.
Co věta říká, je, že neexistuje unitární operace U, kterou bychom mohli aplikovat na X, Y tak, že pokud inicializujeme
Y do stavu nula,
efektivně zkopírujeme nebo klonujeme
libovolné kvantové stavy X.
Pokud se podíváme na tento
výraz přímo zde v izolaci, říká, že pro všechny volby vektoru kvantového stavu Psi X,
aplikace U na Psi tenzorované
se stavem nula nám dá Psi tenzor Psi, nebo jinými slovy dvě
nezávislé kopie Psi,
to je to, co by znamenalo, kdybychom dokázali klonovat kvantové
stavy, a co věta říká, je, že to není možné.
Můžeš o tom přemýšlet
v termínech circuit a věta říká, že nikdy nebudeš schopen přijít s gate nebo circuit,
který funguje, jak vidíš zde.
Kde jedna kopie stavu Psi přichází spolu s kolekcí
inicializovaných qubit a jsou vyprodukovány dvě kopie Psi.
Toto lze udělat pro určité
volby stavu Psi, ale nikdy nemůžeš přijít s
circuit, který funguje takto pro každý kvantový stav Psi,
a to je to, co věta říká.
Tuto větu je celkem snadné
dokázat, ve skutečnosti se v podstatě svodi na skutečnost, že transformace, kterou hledáme, není lineární,
ale unitární operace jsou
lineární, takže to prostě nemůže fungovat.
Zde je argument s trochu více detailů.
Předpokládejme, že máme unitární operaci U, která klonuje standardní bázové
stavy ket 0 a ket jedna.
Víme, že klasické
stavy nula a jedna musí patřit do naší množiny klasických stavů, protože D je alespoň dvě.
Ale to znamená linearitou,
že pokud je X ve stavu plus, který můžeme zapsat takto,
výsledkem je tato lineární kombinace těchto dvou stavů přímo zde.
Ale to není správné chování. Požadavkem na U je, že
U klonuje stav plus,
což znamená, že musí být
splněna tato rovnice přímo zde.
Tyto dva stavy nejsou
stejné a tedy to nefunguje a to je vše.
Jen několik dalších poznámek
k větě o nemožnosti klonování.
Zaprvé, toto formulování věty
o nemožnosti klonování je v jistém smyslu absolutní.
Jednoduše říká, že unitární operace U, která funguje přesně takto,
neexistuje.
Takže bys se mohl zeptat, zda
existuje unitární operace U, která
to dělá přibližně s ohledem na nějaký způsob popisu
WEBVTT
aproximace daného tvrzení. Existují různé
pojmy aproximace, které by mohly být zajímavé,
a několik z nich uvidíme
ve třetí části série, ale pro tyto různé
pojmy aproximace
existují kvantitativní formulování
věty o nemožnosti klonování, která kladou silná omezení na to, jak dobře lze přibližně klonovat.
Druhá poznámka je, že kopírování nebo klonování standardních bázových stavů
rozhodně možné je.
Například řízený NOT gate kopíruje standardní bázové stavy qubit.
To neodporuje
větě o nemožnosti klonování. Pointa je, že klonování ve smyslu věty o nemožnosti klonování vyžaduje,
aby to fungovalo nejen
pro standardní bázové stavy,
ale pro všechny stavy.
Řízený NOT gate
rozhodně neklonuje stav plus například.
A konečně, stojí za zmínku, že existuje také věta o nemožnosti klonování pro
pravděpodobnostní stavy.
Jde jen o něco,
o čem lidé nemluví ani se o to nestarají.
Pokud někdo náhodně
zvolí bit, například pro nějaký libovolný způsob
přiřazení pravděpodobností dvěma hodnotám, a pak ti ten bit podá,
samozřejmě neexistuje způsob, jak získat dvě nezávislé vzorky
tohoto náhodného bitu.
Prostě nevíš, jaké jsou
pravděpodobnosti.
Bit zkopírovat jde, stejně jako řízený NOT
kopíruje standardní bázové stavy, ale to není totéž jako klonování pravděpodobnostního stavu.
Prostě nemáš dostatek
informací k tomu. Jakýkoli náhodný bit, který ti byl dán, ti neřekne, jaké byly
pravděpodobnosti.
Je to jen bit.
Nemožnost klonování
pravděpodobnostního stavu vyplývá přesně ze stejného uvažování jako v kvantovém případě.
Klonování je nelineární proces, zatímco pravděpodobnostní operace, stejně jako unitární operace, jsou lineární.
Každopádně není překvapivé,
že nemůžeme klonovat pravděpodobnostní stav a
nějak to není tak zajímavé jako skutečnost, že nemůžeme
klonovat kvantový stav,
ale pointa je prostě pozorovat, že to není výlučně
kvantový jev.
Poslední omezení
kvantových informací, o kterém budeme v této lekci diskutovat, je, že není možné dokonale rozlišit
dva kvantové stavy, které nejsou ortogonální.
Jiný způsob, jak to říci,
je, že pokud lze dva kvantové stavy dokonale rozlišit, pak musí být ortogonální.
Co máme na mysli, když odkazujeme
na dokonalé rozlišení dvou kvantových stavů Psi a Phi, je, že existuje nějaký
způsob, jak je od sebe odlišit
bez jakékoli šance na chybu.
V termínech modelu kvantového circuit to můžeme vyjádřit, jak
vidíš zde na obrazovce.
Máme nějakou unitární operaci U, která může být implementována
jako kvantový circuit, nebo o U můžeme přemýšlet abstraktně
jako o unitární operaci,
a jako vstup U bere buď stav Psi nebo stav Phi
spolu s hromadou inicializovaných qubit, které si můžeš představit jako pracovní qubit, které nějak pomáhají v tomto
procesu rozlišování.
Po aplikaci U je horní qubit změřen vzhledem k měření ve standardní bázi a zde je ta část s dokonalým
rozlišením.
Pokud byl vstupní stav Psi, pak měření musí
dát výsledek nula, 100 % času, a pokud
byl vstupní stav Phi,
pak měření musí
dát výsledek jedna, opět se 100% šancí.
Není důležité, v jakém
stavu jsou tyto ostatní qubit po aplikaci U.
Záleží jen na tomto jednom bitu, který dostaneme z měření, protože to je bit, který nám říká, se kterým ze dvou stavů jsme začali.
Pro některé volby stavů Psi a Phi bude možné provést dokonalé rozlišení, jako je
toto, a pro jiné nebude.
A co budeme pozorovat, je, že
pokud je to možné udělat, pak Psi a Phi musí být ortogonální stavy
a to znamená, pokud Phi a
Psi nejsou ortogonální, nemůžeš je dokonale rozlišit.
Podívejme se tedy, proč dokonalé rozlišení implikuje ortogonalitu.
Začneme zápisem dvou rovnic, které vyjadřují to, co tyto
dva diagramy vyjadřují.
Pokud přemýšlíme o kvantovém stavu, který dostaneme po aplikaci U na
hromadu inicializovaných qubit spolu se stavem Psi,
vidíme, že musí mít
tuto formu přímo zde, kde Pi nula je nějaký vektor kvantového stavu reprezentující stav
všech těchto qubit
kromě horního. Nemáme žádné informace
o tomto kvantovém stavu Pi nula, může být cokoli,
ale víme, že celý
stav musí vypadat takto, protože to je jediný
způsob, jak je měření zaručeně dá výsledek
nula, 100 % času.
A máme analogickou
rovnici pro druhou.
Tentokrát musí být horní qubit
ve stavu jedna a podobně jako Pi nula, stav
Pi jedna může být cokoli.
A kromě toho, že
nemáme informace o Pi jedna, také nevíme nic
o vztahu mezi Pi nula a Pi jedna.
Pokud víme, jsou to prostě dva
libovolné kvantové stavy.
WEBVTT
Co můžeme dál udělat, je
násobit obě strany těchto rovnic
z obou stran U dagger, tedy konjugovaným transponátem U.
A pokud to uděláme, dostaneme dvě rovnice,
které vidíš přímo zde.
Využíváme skutečnost, že U dagger krát U je matice identity.
Proto nevidíme U ani U dagger na levé straně žádné rovnice.
A nyní můžeme uvažovat skalární součin mezi Psi a Phi.
Je to stejné jako skalární
součin Psi a Phi vynásobený skalárním
součinem stavu L nula se sebou samým
protože skalární součin
libovolného stavu se sebou samým je jedna, a to platí i pro stav L nula.
A nyní, pokud se podíváme na naše dvě rovnice, vidíme, že tento výraz je roven skalárnímu součinu vektorů
reprezentovaných těmito dvěma rovnicemi. A konkrétně je to skalární součin mezi levými stranami
těchto rovnic.
Stejně dobře tedy můžeme
vyjádřit tento skalární součin jako skalární součin vektorů reprezentovaných pravými stranami
těchto rovnic,
protože levá strana se rovná pravé straně pro obě rovnice.
Dostaneme tedy tento výraz přímo zde, což je skalární součin
dvou pravých stran rovnic, nebo ekvivalentně,
je to konjugovaný transponát prvního vynásobený druhým.
U krát U dagger se rovná
matici identity, protože U je unitární, a tedy zmizí.
A můžeme trochu zjednodušit a dostat součin
těchto skalárních součinů.
Pamatuj, že o vztahu
mezi Pi nula a Pi jedna nic nevíme, takže nevíme, jaký je
jejich skalární součin.
To je pro nás záhadou. Ale ať je to cokoli, násobíme to skalárním součinem ket 0 a ket jedna, což je nula.
Takže konečný výsledek je, že
dostaneme hodnotu nula, ale to je to, co jsme chtěli dokázat, skalární součin mezi
Psi a Phi je roven nule.
Takže tyto dva stavy jsou ortogonální.
Takže se neobtěžuj pokoušet
dokonale rozlišit dva neortogonální kvantové
stavy, prostě to nelze udělat.
Existuje obrácené tvrzení k
tomu, co jsme právě dokázali, a to, že ortogonální kvantové stavy lze vždy dokonale rozlišit,
a to není příliš těžké
vidět, pokud využijeme fakt, který jsem zmínil dříve v lekci.
Konkrétně, pokud jsou Psi a
Phi ortogonální stavy, pak jednou z věcí, co můžeme udělat, je zvolit libovolnou unitární matici U
jejíž první dva sloupce
jsou tyto dva stavy.
Víme, že to je vždy
možné udělat a pro účely tohoto úkolu nezáleží na tom, jak přesně je tato unitární matice zvolena.
Důležité je pouze to, že tyto jsou první dva sloupce.
Nepotřebujeme žádné další qubit. Pokud jednoduše aplikujeme U na
dva možné stavy, dostaneme tyto
dva možné výsledky.
A pokud změříme nejvrchnější qubit, který si pamatuj je nejpravnější qubit, pak dostaneme nulu nebo jedničku
v závislosti na tom, se kterým stavem jsme začali.
Alternativně, můžeme uvažovat
projektivní měření s výsledky nula a jedna
definované, jak vidíš přímo zde.
V tomto případě měření
závisí vlastně jen na Psi.
Toto měření dokonale
rozlišuje Psi od libovolného stavu, který je ortogonální k Psi.
Pokud měříme Psi vzhledem k tomuto projektivnímu měření, dostaneme výsledek
nula s pravděpodobností jedna, jak tyto rovnice ukazují.
A pro libovolný stav Phi,
který je ortogonální k Psi, dostaneme výsledek
jedna s pravděpodobností jedna.
Detaily těchto výpočtů
nebudu procházet, ale pokud tě to zajímá, doporučuji ti projít
detaily na vlastní pěst.
A to je konec třetí lekce. V této lekci jsme probrali hodně
materiálu, včetně kvantového circuit,
skalárních součinů a ortonormality, projekcí a projektivních měření, skutečnosti, že globální fáze nezáleží,
věty o nemožnosti klonování a skutečnosti, že neortogonální stavy nelze dokonale rozlišit, zatímco ortogonální stavy ano.
Doufám, že se ke mně brzy přidáš pro
čtvrtou lekci, která je poslední lekcí v
první části série.
Ve čtvrté lekci budeme mluvit o třech
velmi důležitých příkladech: teleportaci, hustém kódování,
a CHSH nerovnosti nebo CHSH hře, jak se někdy nazývá.
Na shledanou do té doby,